i think lucy and i are destined to do a
musical together because
we're both sort of obsessed with them
some of the more obscure ones um um
and i'm always clucking to sort of sing
and dance on screen
um so i often ask lucy to um
you know can i dance in this scene there
and this evening
i just obey her because apparently i
have no will of my own
yeah were you writing specifically with
people in mind for things well you were
thinking about
you know little characters that were in
there um
even like the camera crew you know doing
the photo shooting stuff that was just
perfectly pitched oh thank you yeah i
mean obviously some of that's writing
some of that is performance and a lot of
its direction as well which is
you sort of you make sure that every
single person that comes on the screen
at any moment
has a very full life and
you know i always love and i always love
actors who will come on and go
here's the story of this person that you
see for 15 seconds by the way just in
case you're interested that i've come up
with and they brought it to set and that
sometimes happens and that's always
really
you know actually sounds like a wanky
thing to say but sort of humbling
in a way because as a writer what you
realize is
you sort of wanted them there for this
plot point and they've actually done a
load of work that really elevates
it and i'm always grateful for that
because frankly it makes everyone look
better
um but this we've got loads of questions
that are coming in as well from people
so
i want to get through as many as we can
and we've got one from liam
who says this is a great one actually
and what was it like working with
bsl translator brian duffy on the deaf
character of frank susie son and why did
you decide to include a deaf character
in this series
sure well i um obviously frank was
written as deaf i was i was interested
in the fact that they had a kid together
cobb and susie
um i thought it made the marriage more
interesting and also it made
the dynamic of her being an actress and
a mother it was another role for her to
play essentially and to get wrong
um as well as right and i and i sort of
just wanted to make that as
interesting as possible and also again
it was that question of what do you see
a lot of
in life that you never see done on
screen in a particular way and
i was interested in seeing somebody who
was deaf on screen done in a way that
because i have a
friend of mine who is deaf and she's
just always very very funny about what
it is that's funny about being deaf
you know and the things she gets away
with as a result of it and things like
that
and i was like well that you never
really see could you be quite a naughty
boy you know
and that or this that on the other and
and anyway so
it was just a way of being inspired by
putting something on screen
it was actually dan who did a lot of the
work with sign language and stuff like
that because we decided that cobb maybe
was better at
that i don't know if you want to talk
about working on that down
yeah for sure yeah so we we just well
lucy decided that uh cobb would be
more proficient at sign language and it
was this interesting thing where it was
like
in a way it became like a stick to sort
of beat susie with
that he could communicate with his son
in a way that she couldn't you know and
i think so he
committed to that um in this incredible
way for all of his flaws so i worked
with brian duffy
for about six weeks i want to say maybe
like two or three times a week
and we became good pals he was on set
throughout the shoot as well
and it was you know it's always just
like a joy to have to be able to sort of
dive into something extra like
that's one of the coolest things i think
about being an actor is when you get to
like
learn an instrument or learn a bit of a
language like oh obviously
i didn't have enough time to learn the
whole of bsl um
which uh which would have been awesome
but um particularly because lucy preble
is always rewriting
um but um so we had to figure out some
of that on the fly
but it was wicked you know um it was
interesting talking to
to duffy about he was saying that it's
rare for parents of a deaf child
to be able to speak sign language
properly and so
the example he gave was that like his
own parents don't really speak like
sign language they have their own kind
of like signs and symbols for things
um that basically mean nothing or means
something completely else and bsl
so it was interesting to be able to
portray a character in that way that
like
maybe isn't uh is is kind of rare
and um there's a responsibility there i
think i don't know if you felt this as
well bill there's a responsibility there
to get it right you know what i mean and
to not i what i didn't want to do
was to be like supposedly doing
brilliant sign language in the show
and for people to watch it afterwards
and be like that guy's
talking gibberish um so there was a bit
of a responsibility there
we committed to it
um we've got another question um if you
are putting questions and just put your
name and even one name
you can make up a name if you want
anonymous attendee is really dull
and this is from an anonymous attendee
it says um
will there continue to be musical
numbers throughout
it gives it a unique and surprising feel
uh was that an idea that came early on
thank you anonymous
i think lucy and i are destined to do a
musical together because
we're both sort of obsessed with them
some of the more obscure ones um um
and i'm always clucking to sort of sing
and dance on screen
um so i often ask lucy to
um you know can i dance in this scene
and this evening i just obey her because
apparently i have no will of my own yeah
yeah i mean yeah we do you know although
that is actually quite an inspiring
thing you know when an actor sort of
says to you listen i really really want
to do this thing
it's quite a fun game in your head to go
well how could i possibly do that how
could that happen
um and at least it gives you something
to aim towards
um but yeah the the the i'm afraid that
the truthful
and disappointing answer is that no
there are not loads and loads of some
advanced numbers throughout
but what i would say is that each
episode has
an element that is as extraordinary and
bizarre and fantastical it's just that
that changes depending on what the
emotion of the episode is is that fair
georgie
yeah totally totally and we're not going
to give it away you're just going to
have to wait and see
i'm looking forward to i still hate
susie the musical
[Laughter]
this is another anonymous attendee lucy
aside from billy where are you writing
with particular actors
in mind can you talk a little bit about
the casting process
yeah sure um yeah no i
i i wasn't writing with particular
actors in mind i'm trying to think
back i was thinking of the character
mostly i remember
um dan
jumped out immediately like dan when we
met down and we watched a a i watched a
video first
when he was kind enough to do a reading
the scene and
immediately i thought this person is not
commenting on the character in the way
that sometimes it's easy to do
i think sometimes when you write men in
shows
about women or that just happen to have
women in them
you know there can sometimes be this
tendency to go okay so
is he this terrible terrible
villain monster that we sort of going to
laugh at or is he
this sort of very very nice guy that
everyone
you know sort of loves that sort of gets
shot on and that does that often is a
kind of
broad sitcom thing that goes on with the
casting and the writing of men and
what i wanted to try and do although
obviously i'm always you know a woman
trying to write a man
i was trying to write a guy who was
difficult in a lot of ways
but wasn't totally unlikable and
actually who you could understand a lot
of his aspects i don't know what you
think down but i think there are
occasions with cobb where i'm like
quite on his side actually even though i
think he has issues with how he
expresses himself and anger particularly
is that fair
yeah i mean it's definitely he's
definitely going through stuff as well
and and loads of the
emotions that he's feeling are totally
legitimate i think his behavior is
pretty reprehensible but he's not an out
and out bad guy
and i do think um yeah it's interesting
to hear you say that about the fact that
if you flip it and you look at how so
many male writers write female
characters
and you know this is a pretty obvious
comment but they're so
often incredibly two-dimensional and i
think that
it's uh yeah it's so interesting to see
that like
once you have um
women getting the opportunity to write
these shows that the male characters the
same the same is not true the other way
rounds do you know what i mean
well i mean i you i have to because
you're here
yeah exactly yeah
no but uh but you know that's what drew
me to is it's such a complex character
and i
uh yeah and i think that that needs to
be the case more often
no no that's that's really nice because
you never know that's honestly what i
meant is because you don't know because
you could never be that
you know you never quite know i remember
the first time i saw that like
the first time i saw the adam driver
character on girls i was like oh my god
it's a man written by a woman
like it was first time i remember going
i know who that guy is and it's not that
men have been obviously men have been
writing men brilliantly for centuries
but
that was the first time i sort of
recognized a woman's take on a man that
was
different from what i'd seen before
because it was through her eyes
[Music]
you